pour eux c'est clair et il s'agit d'une
répression syndicale plusieurs dizaines
de personnes étaient réunies pour
soutenir vincent fournier un facteur de
vélizy membres de la cgt convoqué en
conseil de discipline pour
officiellement prise de parole sans
autorisation tous les jours on est sur
le terrain pour rencontrer les facteurs
du département et c'est ce qui les
dérange c'est contester leur politique
tenté d'organiser les luttes avec les
salariés sur le terrain et ils nous
reprochent donc là uniquement des de
prendre la parole et de discuter avec
nos collègues pour la cgt cette
convocation est une manière d'étouffer
toute contestation contre la
réorganisation des services au sein de
la poste la direction de son côté n'a
pas souhaité s'exprimer pour le moment
il y a deux semaines déjà une
manifestation était organisée devant le
tribunal de versailles en soutien à
plusieurs salariés de psa poissy accusé
alors de séquestration sur un chef
d'equipe on sait qu'aujourd'hui dans
l'enseignement social ya plein de gens
qui sont sous le coup de la répression
qui peut aller jusqu'à justice enfin ou
même des emmerdements policiers donc il
ya besoin de la solidarité il ya besoin
de se serrer les coudes et puis de se
défendre nous mêmes de résister à tout
ça parce qu'on sait que au bout du
compte c'est une machine qui cherche à
faire taire qui cherche à museler toute
forme de contestation à l'heure où nous
enregistrons ce reportage l'éventuelle
sanction n'est pas encore connue selon
nos informations l'agent concerné risque
une semaine de mise à pied